[Music]
joanna bryson welcome to how the light
gets in thank you
so
we talked about this a bit earlier you
started out studying behavioral sciences
you later switched to psychology
how does ai fit in all these other
interests of yours well
my first my initial interest when i was
a child was actually well dinosaurs but
after that
it was animal behavior as a big fan of
jane goodall
and i wanted to know in general why were
different species uh using intelligence
in different ways of course i was also
interested in people why do different
people use intelligence in different
ways and why do individual people use
intelligence in different ways at
different times you all know we all know
that sometimes we think and sometimes we
don't
but i also figured out that if you study
people everyone tells you you're wrong
so i thought let's get the animals down
first
and that was really really hard to study
there's no courses in animal behavior i
mean now there sort of is it's called
behavioral ecology but anyway at that
time at university of chicago
non-clinical psychology was called
behavioral science and so i was able
it's a liberal arts degree i was also
able to take biology biological basis of
behavior classes like that
and um
so artificial intelligence i was a
science fiction fan
since i was first forced to read it as
again in middle school it's like you
have to try one of everything like whoa
this is me you know
so uh of course it was an interest
anyway
but i started to realize that it was a
means by which you could um
you could start modeling and
understanding the theories you could
really
do science in a different way if you
build the theory and see if it's
coherent
right so it doesn't it's just like the
rest of science it doesn't necessarily
prove you're right but increases the
probability you
so i
went into artificial intelligence partly
because i enjoyed the idea of trying to
make machines smart and partly because i
wanted to continue doing the science and
i knew i was a really good programmer
and those were sort of thin on the
ground and so it was sort of a safety
for me if i if i had a little more
courage i might have just stuck straight
in like neuroscience or something like
that but i'm glad i did i'm really glad
i went into artificial intelligence as
you said you you got interested in
artificial intelligence through science
fiction of course those are the kind of
main accounts a lot of us are familiar
with and when it comes to fictionalized
accounts of ai they're always a bit
scary right we have like you know the
terminator films like ex machina
do you think these fears are misplaced
is there such a science fiction a kind
of
uh
format of misunderstanding ai rather
than understanding what it really is
okay well i'm going to half disagree
with you because uh they're not always
negative sometimes they're overly
positive so you have data as a super
being and star trek right and uh in fact
you have the computer in star trek and
hal and the the these uh spaceships that
are in cognizant in some sense although
it's interesting that they don't talk
much about the cognizance of of the
enterprise but they do of course with
hal is like definitely this this being
that could even be uh
uh uh
suffers some form of breakdown
so both of these i would say is a
problem it's a problem called
anthropomorphism yeah so the belief that
becoming more intelligent makes you more
like a human just like becoming taller
makes you more like a giraffe right it's
it
this is a a fundamental flaw and it's a
particularly problematic one
because
we
our our entire mode of being our entire
survival basis is social so if we
misattribute what is and isn't a person
then we're in trouble and and this is
actually a conversation it's just having
with one of the other speakers here i
don't believe you can form justice and
trust without peers and so this is one
of the problems that we're suffering now
with these increasing levels of
inequality too that humans aren't even
always curious to each other
or no one's perfect peers of course but
but adequately able to uh uh call each
other to account
but with a with a technology with
something you've actually designed
someone is buying and selling and
designing ai
then there's no way that's up here
right
it's actually uh worse worse than
slavery it's not only owned it's
designed i mean is it possible that ai
does acquire sociability at least
between
other artificial intelligent machines if
not between ai machines and humans
okay so here we go again with the uh the
the idea about acquiring is really
interesting because as i just said it's
designed right so even if a system
changes over time because it's got
machine learning built into it now in
real life
the machine learning usually is used
during the development phases and is no
longer used in production so when you
get to play with the ai it's not
actually learning except in very
carefully specified ways like you can
learn your name it might be maybe it can
learn the layout of your house
if it's a vacuum cleaner most of these
robot vacuum cleaners don't learn the
layout of your house they just bump
around right but even if you had that
even if you as a company sat down and
said i'm going to produce this product
that really is going to develop and
change
that is still the responsibility of the
corporation
so that okay so that was about what will
ai itself acquire yeah will we design
that you think yes so now the question
but so morally that changes a lot
we may design it that way um
and i think what's worse is that um
people may choose to market it in such a
way
that is given legal personality even
though it is actually an extension of a
corporation or a government or some
other powerful individual
right so uh
it's literally buying votes right there
there's this idea there there's again
complete disinformation that sophie the
robot is a citizen of saudi arabia was
never true um it was made a uh honorary
citizen i mean there are so many
constraints about being a citizen of
saudi arabia that sophie the robot
doesn't make you have to be at least
muslim but it's not sufficient to be
muslim but you have to at least be
muslim to be a citizen of saudi arabia
right so
the um
there's a yeah there's a lot of fictions
that are and disinformation spread and
so what i'm worried about is there may
very well be artificial intelligence
that is given uh uh these kinds of legal
powers and that is just going to be a a
entryway a vector into a serious
corruption of our justice system so why
we'll get to the ethical questions in a
bit but why do you think there is so
much misunderstanding around ai you've
touched upon a one the metaphor of
anthropomorphizing
machines and and be the sort of like
marketing side from from companies that
are developing ai what do you are those
the main sources of misunderstanding no
i actually i don't think so although
they of course marketers are very well
motivated to try to make them so uh but
but i do think it's fundamental to how
we socialize that whenever we meet an
entity that we think might be human uh
then we start uh playing sort of in
group out group games we say you know do
you speak english
things like that and try to figure out
can if if you're a teenager you say
what's your favorite band you know you
immediately try to figure out how much
can i trust this entity and so i think
when people are encounter technology
with which they can speak
of course they're going to play those
games of course they're going to see
and they but but it all breaks down so
with a human the fact that i'm spending
this time talking to you really is an
honest signal that i somehow value the
time we have together and that we have
something in common but with a machine
of course it doesn't matter
how long it spends talking to you so the
person may feel confidence because the
machine spent a lot of time at the
beginning uh you know chatting about the
weather or whatever but in fact it's
only cost a tiny amount of electricity
you know and to the corporation or
whatever that that's uh that that's
providing that that facility yeah what
do you make of some of these softwares
that are designed now to
emulate the speech of you know people
that have passed away and people using
them to sort of
try and reconnect in some way with
someone that they love that has is no
longer around but
through a machine that can emulate
somehow their speech yeah so this is a
really interesting question so actually
uh going back to the question you asked
before that was actually my very first
paper
in artificial intelligence was called
just another artifact because a
colleague of mine phil kaim and i were
trying to understand why people were
doing that over identifying thing
um so so coming back to the question you
just asked me
um
so the point of just another artifact is
that it is just another thing it is just
another machine right but
we
humans a vast majority of humans
seriously believe that dead people
have uh concern about their behavior and
even those of us who like self identify
as atheists and naturalists and wouldn't
believe that any supernatural entity
could possibly have concerns about us
we still are going to think sometimes
like oh my grandpa wouldn't approve of
that you know something like that right
so
there's a continuum that that you know
there's been you know enormous rituals
huge sacrifices have been made to to
ancestors uh before so this isn't that
new
yet the fact that you tell someone that
you know when you have the len the the
voice as well
i i just worry about the number of
people that will then invest massive
resources thinking that somehow this is
uh benefiting their actual their their
actual parents or grandparents or or
best friends or whatever
so um
i i do think that these kinds of
sometimes these kinds of obviously we've
we've survived uh for for and maybe it's
strengthened us and empowered us that we
believe
in
the efficacy of of the dead you know so
i'm not saying that we shouldn't have
people shouldn't have those beliefs but
at the same time
if you put too much time if something
can capture a natural thing and then
make you over invest in it then it's a
way to strip resources from you and you
know and that can that can lead to
impoverishment
i was for many years at the university
of bath here and the university of bath
has a center for death in society
and one of the things actually is
similar for weddings but also for
funerals the amount of resources that
people especially poor people feel that
they need to spend on a funeral
you know and it's just it's just
stripping money away from the most
vulnerable and and and it does uh
increase inequality
we we touched well you touched earlier
on some of the ethical kind of concerns
that come out of artificial intelligence
and again a lot of the time we focus on
these kind of catastrophic futures where
ai takes over and you know rules the
world and rules over humans
what do you think are some of the more
pressing and real kind of ethical
challenges when it comes to ai
yeah i i do
it's not really about again it's not
about ai itself as much as the ai can
facilitate this but i do worry that
there will be uh or there may even
already be autocrats that will create
these kinds of ai versions themselves
and then try to leave them power right
you know
so so but i think the real problem there
is about inequality and autocracy
and more generally it's not so much
artificial intelligence itself as the
digital revolution that that you know ai
is literally the face of the digital
revolution
but there's a big question about can we
stabilize democracy when we have so much
information about each other because we
are so good at selling each other things
and so hopefully we can we just need to
be creative it is a project that the
humanities and the social sciences and
sociology and philosophy
to construct a new stable web of people
that so that we can keep things on an
even keel and we can create a
sustainable society but so far we
haven't found that and i kind of think
that autocracy is like weeds you know if
you disrupt if you disrupt ground then
there's these plants that can move in
very quickly and and and and they're
very shallow rooted but they you know
and they're actually an essential part
to stabilizing that ground and then the
more rich ecosystem comes in
so i think that's where we are now that
we need to stabilize what but autocracy
has moved in faster but we have these
you know i don't want to say existential
problems i think they'll still be people
in ten thousand or yeah but so you think
though the problems that arise from ai
aren't to do with the technology itself
necessarily just with the social
conditions that exist at the moment that
produce this kind of technology and this
goes back to the anthropomorphism thing
again i i you
you might want to blame
the technology itself uh and and you
know probably you could get a phd
showing how that's a good reasonable way
to talk about it but the only ones we
can hold to account are the people who
develop own and operate because our
system justice only works on other
humans and so i think it's essential
that we consider we look at it from that
perspective there i i will name uh uh
who's this name uh
pettit pettit and list
yeah yeah they have a nice uh
book talking about corporations as
artificial intelligence
so that's the you know if you do that
then you could say the corporations are
the actors and whatever and then and
then you might have a grip into the the
um
human justice you might get somewhere
with that but but yeah i don't think it
makes sense to reason about the ai
itself being the problem so we obviously
often focus on the negatives when it
comes to air we're worried about all
these ethical consequences what are the
positives that are coming out of this
like why are we building this technology
and what can we expect from it i i
i wouldn't be here except for google
maps i mean right i mean we are all so
much more productive and that again is
one of the questions because people
economists are not good at measuring
that productivity i can see in my day
and i have a pretty good memory i
remember how things used to be how much
better we are at you know grammar and
translation and navigating at purchasing
and fairness and justice there's so many
things that if we do communicate we are
empowering people and then we create new
problems like so by empowering a lot of
people then we suddenly have more
migrants we've ever had before which is
great that's much better than having
people starved to death but it creates
new challenges and not least
sustainability justice stability right
so um i
you know artificial intelligence is just
it's like writing it's something that
you could do bad things with and good
things with and and i think we have to
realize that we've been
phenomenally successful in fact that's
why one of the biggest challenges we
have right now are the problems of a
extremely successful species
sustainability and pandemics are are two
of those things that come when you have
so much success
um but i think we can use artificial
intelligence to solve those kinds of
problems and people are they're they're
in this moment at least with a pandemic
we can't believe how fast we got to the
vaccines we got that was absolutely uh
ai augmenting the great work of great
scientists who were working very hard i
didn't want to say it was you know the
ai doing it but the tools they used were
intelligent and um i think we're also
seeing that in politics and hopefully
we'll find good solutions to the the
greater questions
okay a final question
going back to the theme of
anthropomorphism as aware when we're
designing ai we often sort of look to
human psychology human cognition trying
to replicate it we're trying to do the
same with robots when we you know
develop them we start making them look
like humans do you think that's the
wrong direction we should be doing
something different right well again i'm
going to uh go back
to what i did with the first couple of
questions and challenge you a little bit
about that
like what i just mentioned some of the
most pervasive ai we see is like the the
um
the spell checking the the navigating
the the the recommender systems amazon
helping you find the things you want to
buy whatever
all that ai is not even remotely
human-like and and it's that's the vast
majority of the ai so
the subset that we call again as i say
it's the part of the digital revolution
that that has a face on that we that we
identify with that tiny subset
should we be building that that's a
really interesting ethical question so
originally i was doing it as i said my
phd was in building human-like
intelligence making it easier to build
that um because i was a scientist
because i wanted to understand
human-like intelligence and that's
excuse me a lot of us use it
now some people are saying we need to do
this because some people are lonely and
it helps them not be lonely um
for example and uh
there's a real question about that
because uh it's like every other like
form of welfare that that um
yes some people cannot you know hang out
with other people in the same way on the
other hand if they
some people if they force themselves out
a little more would help hold society
together better
so that's an interesting question and
then the other side of it is
we are so social that we um we
automatically update and change our
behavior if there's humans around us we
we conform
if a lot of the things that appear to be
humans around us are again owned by uh
corporations or governments
they can channel us and change who we
are so i am aware of people who believe
there is no moral way to have natural
language processing in the home and
these are not people that started out
that way these are just technologists
that worked in companies but were trying
to make sure that they were trying to
find ways to ameliorate um sorry to
reduce the kinds of problems they have
from people talking to you know alexa or
something like that in their house and
they came to the conclusion there's no
way to do it we will definitely change
the culture of the household if these
tools are inside of it because language
matters that much to people
jonah bryson thank you very much well
thank you
you